قبل اكثر من ثلاث سنوات فشل التوافق بين
المدنيين والمجلس العسكري في السودان في
اداره الفتره الانتقاليه وادى التوتر الذي
طغى بين المقاولين الاعتقال المجلس
العسكري لعبد الله حمدوك رئيس الحكومه
انذاك ووضعه قيد الاقامه الجبريه وبدا
المشهد في السودان شديد الضبابيه والتعقيد
فسعت الاليه الثلاثيه في السودان والمؤلفه
من ممثل الامين العام للامم المتحده ورئيس
بعثه
والاتحاد الافريقي بالاضافه الى الهيئه
الحكوميه لتنميه وسط وشرق افريقيا ايجاد
الى ايجاد حلول تمهد الاتفاق ايطالي بين
القوى المدنيه والعسكريه في السودان
يتناول قضايا جوهريه تشمل تشكيل حكومه
مدنيه والاتفاق على قضيه العداله
الانتقاليه وتقييم اتفاقيه السلام وكذلك
الاصلاح الامني والعسكري لكن اصطدمت
الاليه الثلاث كثيره ابرزها ارتبط بسنوات
دمج الدعم السريع داخل مؤسسه الجيش كما
واجهت معضله انسحاب الجيش من الحوار ما
اجبر الاليه على تعليقه عقب هذا التعقيد
نشطت المجموعه الرباعيه في السودان والتي
تتشكل من السعوديه والامارات والولايات
المتحده وبريطانيا في محاوله مع الاليه
الثلاثيه في لعب دور اكبر في الوساطه بين
المكون المدني والعسكري لتقريب وجهات
النظر وايجاد ارضيه مشتركه تسمح لها
بتسهيل الحصول على الدعم الذي يحتاجه
السودان لمواجهه ازماته الاقتصاديه حنان
المصري العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات